[Musique]
charles neuf catherine de médicis
marguerite de valois des visages
légèrement de trois quarts sur fond
neutre
saisissant de réalisme peint par l'un
des plus grands portraitistes de
l'époque françois cloud et techniquement
ce sont des chefs-d'oeuvre
ils sont peints sur bois c'est de la
peinture à l'huile
donc c'est une technique qui vient des
flandres qui ne vous voyez on ne voit
pas la touche du peintre c'est
extrêmement précis extrêmement minutieux
et ça va faire le bouillonnement la
fortune de c2c portrait ils vont être
très recherchée sur tout ce qu'on aimait
beaucoup à l'époque s'il y avait une
véracité c'est à dire qu'on reconnaît
ses personnages représentés et ça
c'était une grande nouveauté
ces portraits sont de retour pour l'été
dans leur ancienne demeure en touraine
au 19e siècle
les propriétaires du château
d'azay-le-rideau la dynastie de
billancourt s'était constitué une des
plus grandes collections de portraits
pour les légitimer leur rang social
c'est une grande famille de
l'aristocratie plutôt monarchiste donc
et qui va vouloir asseoir son rang et
finalement expliciter ses origines
aristocratiques par la collection et par
la réunion de tous les portraits des
grands illustres de l'histoire de france
victime de mauvais placements la famille
on avait revendu une partie au duc
d'orléans à leur propriétaire du château
de chantilly pose des vitres dernières
retouches de peinture et ajustement des
éclairages l'exposition sera fin prête
pour le grand jour le 19 mai il faut
être au service de l'oeuvre de ce que
l'on vient voir on vient pas voir une
scénographie on vient voir des oeuvres
d'art on voulait que les regards soient
soit là là l'intensité de l'exposition
[Musique]
exclusivement exposé au château de
chantilly dans l'oise depuis 1939
ses peintures sont donc proposés à
nouveau en touraine dans l'un des plus
beaux joyaux du val de loire